Good morning Hank,
it’s Tuesday. So three
and a half years ago,
I was diagnosed with a disease
called labyrinthitis, wherein part
of my inner ear became inflamed
due to a viral infection.
All at once, I went from
feeling like I had a bit of a
head cold to being completely
incapacitated by vertigo.
I fell over, began vomiting and
was rushed to the hospital.
In the years since, I’ve had
a lot of treatment for labyrinthitis,
and I’ve started to wonder:
Is this disease mental
or physical?
Let me just begin by noting
how profoundly we stigmatize
mental illness: When I was in
the hospital, there was initially
some thought that my vertigo
might be psychosomatic--
that the dizziness could be caused
by my chronic anxiety.
And I have to confess that
once they found an ostensibly
physiological cause for my vertigo--
I was a little relieved because
suddenly everyone was acting
as if--and I started feeling as
if--my illness was really real.
But of course, mental illness
is also really real, and often
has a physiological cause.
Like, the brains of many
people who have OCD,
as I do, look different in
fmri scans than the brains
of other people. We just
don’t really understand those
differences very well yet. And
illnesses that are poorly
understood or lack effective
treatments tend to be heavily
stigmatized--see also,
endometriosis and irritable
bowel syndrome and many
pain disorders and leprosy.
Rarely do I need a footnote
in a video, but I do need one here.
The category of mental illness
is just that: a category.
It has uses, and it has
limitations, and remembering
that categories are often
useful but almost always
limited seems to me one
of the big challenges of life
right now. Like, the extremely
silly discourse about whether
a hot dog is a sandwich is of
course very silly, but underneath
it lies something important,
which is that we want categories
to be strict and inviolable,
when in fact they are messy
and constructed.
But right, so I got labyrinthitis,
which is not a psychological
illness, or at least I’m told
it’s not. I went home from the
hospital with two medications:
One is a central nervous
depressant called meclizine,
and the other an anti-anxiety
medication called Diazepam
that also lessens vertigo. Both
these medications were
psychotropic in the sense
that they affected the way
I experience consciousness,
and both of them are sometimes
prescribed as psychiatric
medications, but in my case
they weren’t psychiatric
medicines, because in my case
my illness was not
considered psychiatric.
Both these medications reduced
my symptoms while I recovered,
but I eventually found that even
after I was mostly better
and the virus was gone,
I still had some long term
problems with my vestibular
system, so my doctor sent me
for therapy at a
Balance Institute.
So I went to this place to
retrain my brain’s balance system,
and while I was there the
therapist said to me,
“We’re just trying to
rewire your brain,” and in that
moment I realized, this is just
like that other therapy I go to.
In regular therapy, I am trying
to get my brain to respond
differently to unreliable anxious
thoughts, and in this therapy
I am trying to get my brain to
respond differently to unreliable
inner ear information.
Now the exercises and
medicines used to treat
OCD are very different
from those to treat labyrinthitis,
but the underlying
idea is similar. Medication
and therapy. And so is it a
mental or physical illness?
Yeah. Yes, it is.
I find myself going back again
and again to Elaine Scarry’s
observation in The Body in Pain:
To have great pain is to have
certainty; to hear that another
person has pain is to have doubt.
I think that doubt compounds
the suffering of people in pain,
and I think it is further compounded
when we imagine that someone’s
pain is less real because it involves
the mind, or because an observer
can’t see it. The truth is, the
body/mind dichotomy is as
insufficient as the category
of sandwiches. Our minds
are made out of body,
and our bodies think--in fact,
on Earth at least, bodies
are the only things that think.
Whether we call it mental or
physical, other people’s
pain is as real as our own.
Hank, I’ll see you on Friday.